welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and if you can't wait for
season two of sweet tooth then this is
the video for you
though toni this show is quite different
to the source material
there are several similarities and
characters that appear in both
properties
in this video we're going to be breaking
down the full comic book storyline
and what happens at the end of the
source material now i want to tell this
story chronologically as i think that's
the way it will make the most sense
in order to do that though we actually
have to start off at volume five of the
graphic novel run
our story begins in 1911 with an
expedition to the arctic
led by dr james thacker thakur is
attempting to rescue a man named louie
who he met in medical school and who
also happens to be engaged to his sister
in the wilderness he comes across the
character who kills the dogs in james's
group
and attempts to warn them off from
following him home they ignore this and
discover that he has been living with
the alaskans
and has had a child with one who just so
happens to be half human and half deer
james in his group unearthed an
underground shrine dedicated to
creatures like this
and in the native culture they are
regarded as gods the hybrids are thought
to purify the world upon their
arrival and thus the child carries a
disease that's extremely lethal to
humans
louis knows this and says he doesn't
want james and his group to contract it
and he sends them on their way
unfortunately james is a stubborn man
and there are flashes of abbott in him
who we'll be talking about later on
james returns to the camp with his men
and they murder everyone there
they are worried that they've been
infected and think that if they manage
to kill the child
the virus within them will cease to
exist now james throws this baby into a
cave
and seals it up with a boulder and then
sets off back home
the virus doesn't go away though and on
the ship he and his men die
james worried that this might all happen
again and left notes in a journal
which detailed his journey this journal
is later found
and the science team at fort smith carry
out a dig at the alaskan site
which is where they discover the bones
of the hybrids in the shrine
the fort smith scientists managed to
recreate a living hybrid
and they call it gus one night a janitor
named richard stumbles across a
scientist in the lab dying
and he takes the journal of james
thacker along with the child
the disease quickly spreads and it
starts to wipe out humanity
and thus richard heads to the nebraskan
wilderness which is where
he starts to raise gus on his own
richard starts to read the journal
and slowly becomes more and more
convinced that it prophesizes the end of
humanity
he teaches curse life skills but lies to
him about the rest of the world
and says that the entire planet is on
fire to keep him in the enclosure
the boy has nightmares of a tall man who
is coming to get him
and his father slowly succumbs to the
sick and dies at the cabin
now dreams play a big part of the comic
there's often this prophetic use of them
which tells the future
and also allows characters across great
distances to connect with one another
ghost ventures out into the woods and
here he's almost killed by hunters
however a man named jeopard arrives and
saves his life
and he promises to take him to a
sanctuary called the preserve
filled with people just like him the
pair set off on the road and run into
some cultists dressed as animals
and whereas in the show these are the
animal army led by bear
here they're malevolent forces that
jeopard ends up killing
jeopard gets brutally damaged by them
and almost bleeds to death
but gus saves his life and after eating
all of his chocolate
jeopard nicknames him sweet tooth whilst
making their way to the preserve
they come across a man and woman who we
discover are holding girls hostage
and forcing them into a life of
prostitution shepard ends up killing the
man
but a woman named lucy steps forward to
murder the female
they hint that the preserve isn't what
gus thinks it is and this turns out to
be true
when jeopard takes gus there what we
find are repurposed barracks
that have been turned into somewhat of a
concentration camp
now it's at this point that we sort of
get jeopard's backstory and we learned
that before the plague swept humanity
that he was a hockey player his wife
fell pregnant and when society started
to collapse
they went out into the world on the road
they were attacked by hunters
but a man named general abbott managed
to save the pair
he appeared to be friendly at first but
upon arriving
at the base he locked shepard in a cage
and started to experiment on his wife
louise
jeppard was visited by a man named
johnny who he learned was general
abbott's brother
he struck up a friendship with him and
eventually johnny let him free jebed
found his wife about to give birth
and he learned that abbott and a man
named dr singh had been experimenting on
pregnant women in the hybrids
in order to find a cure for the sick
shepherd went toe to toe with abbott
but he was easily bested abbott then
threw him out the camp
and told him that his wife and child
died in labour jeb had always promised
to take his wife home
and abbott said that he would give him
her bones in exchange for a hybrid child
now it turns out that jeopard hasn't
been the kind guardian that we thought
and upon arriving at the preserve he
hands gus over to the general
it's a big gut punch i think this is
where the series
massively differs from the comics in my
ending explained video i said the show
feels
somewhat a kidified version of the
source material and though i really
enjoyed the first season
things are pretty bleak from the outset
in the graphic novel
gurs meets the other captives there
namely a pig girl named wendy
a groundhog called bobby and another
dear boy who we learn is called buddy
ghost then meets doctor singh a
disheveled man who realizes that sweet
tooth is something special
after seeing that he doesn't have a
belly button throughout the first volume
gus constantly talks about how he's nine
even though the hybrids
only emerged seven years ago no one
really believes him
but this revelation shows that he might
have been created in a lab
singh hypnotizes him and in his
subconscious
gurus tells him of his home and where
it's located
sing inhabit head there and discover
thakur's journal
singh becomes absolutely obsessed with
it and he starts to believe that gus
is actually a god at the camp johnny
befriends the kids
and he lets them free they head to the
sewers and in the underground they're
attacked by
what seems to be a crocodile ghost kills
it
and it's only after doing this that he
realizes it's actually a hybrid child
like them
that was just hiding out below the base
now during this escape
gus has a shared dream with jeopard and
the two meet face to face
using their psychic connection they
managed to talk to one another
and right now i'm using my psychic
connection to make you like the video
also yeah if you're enjoying the
breakdown then don't forget to subscribe
as we do videos like this every day
anyway now it turns out that since
leaving the camp
jebed actually returned home and buried
his wife after feeling the guilt and
shame of what transpired
he returned to lucy and we learned that
she and the other girls were
experimented on at the preserve
they agreed to go and save the children
and together they all head out
jeopard also starts to work with a group
known as the animal army
who you will of course know from the
show now where things differ from the
the more cuddly game playing tv show
counterparts
is that the animal army in the comics is
a cannibalistic cult
their leader has several dog hybrid
children and we learn that when his wife
gave birth to the first thatchy tried to
kill it
however he stayed her hand and she ended
up giving birth to four more
almost immediately after this completely
exhausted her
and the leader made the pups feed on her
body whilst she was still alive
they're the ultimate psychopaths but
because they don't hate the hybrids
jeopard sees them as allies during this
time gus and co are captured
and they are taken back to the camp
jebet storms it
and the first place they go to is of
course the kennels
here they rescue most of the kids but
the cult leader
sicks his dogs and buddy lucy tries to
save him
but jeopard pulls her away and says that
they have to leave him
which is where buddy says dada we learn
that this is actually jeopard's child
and that abbott lied about him dying
jeopard has very much left his child to
die
i think that in season two it will be
revealed that one of the children at the
end
is his kid i think the main structure of
season two will be based around jeopards
storming the camp with amy
and they may even call on bear to help
reform the animal army
in order to lead the church i think the
season will culminate is
exactly the same way as the book does
and at the base
jeopard comes face to face with abbott
once more he's bested again
but johnny saves him and blows up his
brother's fingers with a rifle
the group escape with sing and though we
think that buddy is dead
it is revealed that he's not abbott
saves his life
and ends up taking him captive he also
kills the animal army leader
and takes his dog children under his
command out in the wilderness some of
the girls spring a trap
and a crippled man named walter arrives
and saves their lives
he takes them to a giant dam which he
tells lucy was a location headed up by
an organization
called project evergreen walder says
that the woods surrounding the dam are
extremely dangerous
and that they're littered with savages
led by a ruthless man named hagerty
he says that they'll be safe in his damn
and that they can live there with
everything they need
but it does seem too good to be true gus
is attacked by a bear and dragged off
back to its cave
but jeopard arrives and manages to kill
it now here jeopard starts to suspect
that something is off with walter
and things get a lot worse for the group
during this time
lucy also begins to succumb to the sick
and sing has a revelation
upon reading the journal he comes across
the prophecy that a malevolent entity
known as the white demon will kill sweet
tooth
and he believes that this is jeopard one
day when they're outside the group are
seemingly attacked
by what they believe to be haggardy's
men around this time
jeopard also takes gus out into the
woods and he confesses that he killed a
crocodile hybrid boy
and says that he regrets it just before
jeopard fully consults him
gus is shot by a mysterious rifleman and
he's taken back to the dam
dr singh has to operate on him in order
to save his life
and he's given a blood transfusion from
wendy during this he has a dream about
going to the arctic
that pretty much fills in the blanks
about dhaka's expedition
here he comes across dhaka's massacre
and also discovers the murdered hybrid
from the start of the story
though he's saved everything comes to
boiling point and tempers flare with
jeopard going wild on walter
he tells him to drop the act and says
that he knows he's lying
jeopard is kicked out of the dam and
from here he ends up living in the
surrounding woods
gus and singh visit him regularly but
it's clear that those back at the dam
want nothing to do with him gus says he
wants to take him to alaska
but jebet says no and continues to go
off into the woods on his
own here he stumbles across the camp
that initially seems like it's full of
haggardy's men
however this is actually project
evergreen and it's revealed that
walter is in fact haggerty we discovered
that haggerty came to the dam one day
and pretended to be a kind man
however he lied and when they left the
base to go hunting
he killed the real walter and took his
wife and daughter he put walter's body
at the door as a warning
and we never learned what happened to
either of the women
however walter's daughter had a pig toy
that looked a lot like
wendy and she herself had a lot of
similarities to becky
one of the girls in the group now it
turns out that haggerty has been waiting
for most of the men to leave
and he launches his attack he beats the
crap out of johnny
and ties the girls up lucy is at death's
door
and far too weak to fight back and it
seems like they're now completely doomed
jeopard heads out there immediately but
on the roads his car
overturns luckily he's saved by a man
called fat man
who just so happens to be a rival hockey
player from years ago
at this time singh kidnaps gus and
starts driving north
but gus manages to escape and he heads
back to the dam
jeopard and fat man ice skate there and
together they managed to defeat hagerty
lucy is instrumental in taking him down
but unfortunately
it proves to be too much and she dies in
shepard's arms
haggety heads out into the woods around
the area and when they bury lucy they
discover his body
project evergreen returns to the dam and
johnny and bobby decide to remain there
bobby needs to hibernate and they're
just not ready for the rest of the
journey to the arctic
now during all of this abbott has been
tracking the group with the dog hybrids
he arrives at the dam and then kills all
of project evergreen
it's here that we really get his and
johnny's backstory and we learn that
their father was a cruel man
that used to beat johnny badly his
brother would often stay his hand
and when the plague hit abbott was
called to go and defend the canadian
border
johnny remained behind to care for his
dad whose conditions slowly got worse
and worse
and when he went out looking for
supplies he was attacked by strangers
abbott ended up saving his life and he
told him that he'd killed their father
so that johnny could be free
and they ended up traveling to an army
barrack abbott killed the leader there
and took over the command
and eventually this turned into the
preserve though johnny repeatedly broke
his brother's rules he constantly let
him off and because of this
abbott realized that he was his one
weakness abbott starts to interrogate
him to find out where the rest of the
group have gone
but he refuses to give them up they've
been through this numerous times and
johnny says he knows that his brother
won't kill him but abbott
shoots him in the head at point-blank
range bobby runs out into the wilderness
and abby catches him
and he tells him that everyone has gone
to alaska abbott throws him in with
buddy and at alaska we find singh
retracing richard's footsteps
this very much falls in the details of
the outbreak and singh starts to see
himself as someone who's been trying to
cure the virus
rather than ushering the path in in
which he will purify the earth
jeopard gurus and the rest of the group
arrive in alaska
and here they discover the truth about
the hybrids and of course the virus
bobby is sent into town as a warning
from abbott and the survivors decide to
make a last stand
fat man and jeopard set traps in the
town and here they go head to head with
abbott's forces
that man is killed and jeopard realizes
that this was all a distraction
and the abbot has really gone to the lab
he and singh head there and find abbott
holding gus in his son hostage
he says that he must choose between the
two but before jeopard makes a decision
several hybrids from the town arrive and
help to kill abbott's forces
abbott grabs buddy and heads into the
lab and jeopard goes after him
unfortunately he slips and breaks his
leg and just as he's about to kill him
abbott asks why he's doing all of this
jebet says that
it's because he loves the hybrids and
it's at this moment that gus arrives and
kills abbott
sadly jeopard dies from his wounds and
in his last words he tells gus to look
after buddy
now we then get somewhat of a redo with
a boy that looks like gus
out in the woods being chased by hunters
he's grabbed by another hybrid
who looks slightly like a cross between
wendy and gus
and we learn that this character is
called tommy tommy was actually the
first name of jeopard
and he leads the child away as the
hunters pursue
they're killed by what's revealed to be
an older sweet tooth and we learn that
these two children
are in fact his sons it turns out that
when the group left alaska
they returned to nebraska namely where
gus was raised
here they built the community and gus
fell in love with becky
unfortunately she died from the sick and
he ended up
starting a relationship with wendy
humanity is on its last legs and buddy
arrives to say that the last men are
launching a war party to try and take
the hybrids out once and for all
gus is initially wary about whether
they're attacking or not
and he believes that they just want
shelter however he does
eventually meet buddy on the battlefield
in order to fight them off
it's a landslide for the hybrids but
rather than killing the humans
they offer them safety and shelter they
don't want any more deaths
and allow them to live with the hybrids
for the next couple of years slowly
humanity succumbs to the sick
and gus and co bury the last of them
they have learned from our mistakes
and want to make the world a better
place gus's children head out into the
world
and he has many grandkids he recounts
stories of the tall man
and adventures as a child to them in his
home happy with his family and the world
he's helped to create
gus dies in his chair as an old man and
the book ends with the spirit of jeopard
taking his young soul away to heaven
it's a touching end to this
incredible story so i swear it get it
gets us every time this better but
i'm not i'm not crying now now the
graphic novel
is incredible and if you enjoyed this
video then i definitely recommend that
you pick it up
it's easily one of the best releases
this side of the millennium
and though the show changes things up i
think the core story is absolutely
incredible
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below and
let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
throughout the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase 3 box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the series
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now saying that to
you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the series itself which will be linked
on screen right now
we went over the full first season from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
watching if you want to know more
without the way thank you for saying
through the video i've been paul i'll
see you next time
take care peace